le hand fauteuil à l'honneur un tournoi
se tenait ce samedi 18 novembre à
Montini le bretonux au total six équipes
mixtes de personnes en situation de
handicap et valide se sont affronté
toute la journée c'est donné aussi une
possibilité aux personnes valides de
d'avoir un changement de vue sur le
handicap se rendre compte que c'est des
gens comme vous et moi et que voilà on
peut on peut bien profiter bien s'amuser
avec eux il y a viennent pour le pour
s'amuser et moi je fais du sport depuis
40 ans donc j'ai un esprit de
compétition tout le temps je veux gagner
en fait une solidarité sur le terrain
mais aussi de la part des visiteurs ils
étaient plusieurs centaines à se rendre
à l'événement et participer à la
collecte de fonds mise en place pour
l'association Les Restos du cœur c'est
important déjà pour se faire connaître
et puis comme C au manque d'argent en ce
moment on va être obligé de restreindre
sur la campagne qui arrive la quantité
nourriture le nombre de personnes
accepté et donc plus on a d'argent plus
on pourra aider un espoir entendu par
les participants l'événement a collecté
plus de 4300 € pour l'antenne
yvelinoise